this is not meant to be alarmist
but hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome
to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we'll be debunking the myths
around pre-diabetes and i'll be giving
my expert top tips on reducing the risk
of type 2 diabetes but first let me tell
you what my sponsor acorns so as a
business owner homeowner and a mama too
i need to now start thinking a little
more seriously about my family's
finances i know i know i know i look
like i'm 20 but your girl is no spring
chicken
so i just learned about acorns which is
a zero to one savings and investing app
that helps people save and invest in the
background of their life i am admittedly
not very money savvy i actually always
feel really overwhelmed with the options
for investing because i just really
don't know enough about them to make an
educated choice but you don't need any
prior knowledge or expertise to save
with acorns they have a number of
features that help make saving money
easy
without needing to make any major
behavioral changes which is really key
for people like me who don't do so well
with abrupt lifestyle change let's be
real who does but acorns is most known
for their roundup feature which allows
you to round up all of your purchases to
the next dollar and invest your spare
change in the background of your life so
let's say you get a starbucks for five
dollars and fifty cents it rounds up to
six dollars and you invest the 50 cents
this can be so helpful for busy people
because you actually don't even have to
think about the transaction they also
have a smart deposit feature that allows
you to automatically save and invest a
certain percentage of your paycheck they
have the acorns early program which is
an investment account for your kids and
they have the acorns later feature which
is an automated way to invest for your
retirement so if you want to check out
acorns yourself head to the link in my
description to get a bonus ten dollars
when you start saving and investing with
acorns and you can pause the screen or
look at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating so as
always feel free to skip this video if
it is not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that subscribe button and follow me over
on tick tock and instagram abby's
kitchen also a big thank you to my
colleagues alita finney and janice baker
for their help and expertise on this
video this is a very big topic but i'm
going to try to keep it as simple as i
can so pre-diabetes occurs when blood
sugar levels are higher than normal but
not high enough to warrant a diabetes
diagnosis this suggests that our cells
are starting to become resistant to
insulin which causes glucose to build up
in the bloodstream instead of being used
for energy there is a lot of ground to
cover here so let's unpack some of the
big myths and tips for managing
pre-diabetes myth one having
pre-diabetes means it's just a matter of
time before you have diabetes so this is
a valid concern as five to ten percent
of people with pre-diabetes will develop
type 2 diabetes every year but even
though you are technically at an
increased risk the good news here is
that this trajectory can be reversed or
delayed through lifestyle changes we
even have long-term data suggesting that
lifestyle interventions like physical
activity and diet can decrease
pre-diabetes progression for as long as
10 years ultimately the goal here is to
reverse insulin resistance by making our
cells more insulin sensitive in other
words we want to make our cells more
responsive to insulin so that they can
efficiently absorb glucose from the
bloodstream and then lower the sugar in
our blood one of the best ways to
increase insulin sensitivity is through
regular exercise in fact one review of
the literature confirmed that regular
physical activity can help to improve
blood sugar levels and slow down the
progression of diabetes this is because
physical activity drives glucose into
the muscle which helps to boost insulin
sensitivity anywhere from 2 to 48 hours
post-workout so over time regular
physical activity can boost our insulin
sensitivity long-term thereby helping to
ward off diabetes progression not only
that but any reduction in visceral
abdominal fat specifically has also been
shown to improve insulin sensitivity so
exercise may be able to play an indirect
role here as well however it's very
important to note that visceral fat is
independent of body size so in other
words you can have a larger body and be
physically lean with little abdominal
fat or be in a smaller body and have
higher amounts of abdominal fat which
can ultimately impact insulin resistance
and this speaks to why bmi is not such a
great measure of health but we already
knew that obviously now in terms of
exercises that are most effective at
boosting insulin sensitivity one
meta-analysis found that aerobic
exercise and resistance training had the
most significant effect so for example
one study on non-diabetic participants
found that 60 minutes of cycling
increased insulin sensitivity for 48
hours post-workout another study on men
with insulin resistance found that
strength training over a three-month
period also improved insulin sensitivity
now of course we want to think about
small manageable changes that you can
sustain long term rather than like
jumping into this like six day a week
program when maybe you've never
exercised before in your life
[Music]
so this might look like going for a walk
or biking to work a few days a week
instead of driving uh maybe taking the
stairs instead of the elevator doing
some bodyweight exercises or
experimenting with weights or resistance
bands and don't forget that daily
activities like cleaning gardening or a
brisk walk also count myth number two
you need to cut carbs now when we eat
carbs it breaks down to sugar in the
body aka glucose which naturally raises
our blood sugar levels now for someone
who isn't insulin resistant the cells
are able to respond to the boost in
insulin let the sugar into the cells for
energy and then return blood sugar to
normal levels but in someone with
pre-diabetes who is becoming insulin
resistant the cells aren't as responsive
to insulin and therefore the blood sugar
levels remain higher than normal so if
you're trying to get your blood sugar
levels under control i can definitely
understand the knee-jerk reaction to
want to cut out all the carbs however
when we look at the larger body of
research low-carb diets have not
actually been shown to significantly
improve blood sugar levels compared to
normal or higher carb diets in fact
certain carbs may actually be highly
beneficial in blood sugar management as
a source of fiber and research has
consistently shown that soluble fiber
specifically can slow down glucose
absorption and improve post meal blood
sugar levels in fact one study found
that those who ate more soluble fiber
had lower levels of insulin resistance
another interesting factoid is that
soluble fiber helps to feed good gut
bacteria which can also help to lower
our insulin resistance not only that but
soluble fiber from foods like oats
barley and psyllium have been shown to
help lower cholesterol levels which is
another risk factor for developing
diabetes there are even diabetes
prevention studies showing that high
fiber diets combined with moderate
intensity physical activity help to
reduce the risk of diabetes by a
whopping 58
so the goal is to reverse diabetes
progression we definitely don't want to
sleep on those high fiber carbs the
ideal strategy here would be to obtain
fiber from a combination of different
types and sources of carbs including
fruits vegetables whole grains nuts
seeds and legumes and aim for 25 to 38
grams of fiber a day with that said it's
also important to pay attention to carb
quality as not all carbs are made equal
and some carbs will have a drastically
different effect on blood sugar levels
than others this is what we call the
glycemic effect of food otherwise known
as the glycemic index some carbs have a
higher glycemic index like white bread
meaning they will raise blood sugar
levels quicker whereas lower gi carbs
will help to slow down the release of
sugar into the bloodstream research has
even shown that replacing high gi foods
with low gi foods has shown clinically
significant improvements in blood sugar
levels for folks with diabetes so while
we definitely want to be prioritizing
high fiber low gi carbs it's also worth
noting that carbs are not usually eaten
in isolation but rather in combination
with other foods so even if a food has a
high glycemic index like white rice for
example if we combine this with a source
of protein fat and fiber aka make it a
hunger crushing combo it can help to
mediate the blood sugar response so for
example one study found that creating a
mixed meal of rice combined with bean
sprouts for fiber egg for protein and
oil for fat significantly lowered the
blood sugar response compared to just
eating the rice alone so this is all
just to say that we do not need to cut
carbs to prevent diabetes or even
sacrifice our favorite carbs if they
happen to fall higher on the glycemic
index instead we would want to focus on
carbohydrate quality by prioritizing
higher fiber lower glycemic index carbs
and or ensuring that we are dressing up
those carbs with a source of protein fat
and fiber to help slow down the blood
sugar response and now that we are on to
the topic of carbs let's discuss another
common diabetes myth you need to go
keto given the rise and popularity of
the keto diet many have jumped on the
keto bandwagon as a way to help manage
their blood sugar levels by drastically
reducing carb intake on top of that
because weight loss is a common
recommendation for those at risk of
diabetes many have turned to weight loss
diets like keto as a quick fix so even
though we know there's tons of research
support in the consumption of high fiber
carbs for the prevention and management
of diabetes is the keto diet necessary
or even safe have no fear safety is here
well technically the keto diet may help
to improve blood sugar levels given that
carbs are being drastically reduced
thereby lowering the needs for insulin
in the first place in fact one study
found that the keto diet helped to
improve blood sugar levels and
medication reduction in folks with
diabetes however what we aren't so sure
of is whether or not keto benefits or
further destroys insulin sensitivity
it's kind of a mixed bag of research in
this space most of the research
suggesting that keto may improve insulin
sensitivity suggests that it's likely
only a temporary improvement and not
permanent for example one study saw
improvements at six months but this was
not maintained after a year on top of
that we also know that higher intakes of
dietary fat may increase the risk of
elevated cholesterol levels and other
cardiovascular risk factors which again
we know increases the risk of diabetes
but of course this largely depends on
the type of fat as diets high in healthy
unsaturated fats don't appear to have
the same effects we also have research
showing that keto diets high in animal
proteins and fats are associated with a
two-fold increase in type 2 diabetes
whereas a keto diet high in plant-based
protein and fats was associated with a
decreased risk so again it really comes
down to diet quality of the foods
included in the diet not necessarily
the absence of carbohydrates so with all
that said do you absolutely need to go
on a keto diet to get your blood sugar
levels under control
no
especially if it's not something that
you think you could maintain long term
in fact the diabetes clinical practice
guidelines consistently recommends a
diet containing high fiber carbs for the
management of diabetes like the
mediterranean diet for example but can
the keto diet benefit some folks yeah of
course it might but again we don't have
enough long-term research to recommend
this across the board especially because
we know that the keto diet has very low
adherence and weight cycling or yo-yo
dieting also puts one at greater risk
for metabolic syndrome and diabetes so
if you are considering the keto diet to
miniature blood sugars it's really
important to weigh the risks and the
benefits and to work closely with a
registered dietitian all right moving on
to myth number four eating sugar causes
diabetes this is among the most common
myths that i hear when it comes to
diabetes and pre-diabetes so before you
decide to forgo the sugar in your coffee
i want to start out by saying diabetes
is a highly complex disease and there
are multiple factors that can increase
your risk in fact many risk factors for
diabetes aren't even within our control
family history of diabetes is a very
strong predictor of diabetes and
pre-diabetes so one study found that
family history increased the risk of
pre-diabetes by 26
older age and a history of gestational
diabetes are also major factors as for
the risk factors that are within our
control diet of course does play an
important role but so does physical
inactivity and smoking in other words if
your dad has diabetes you smoke every
day live a sedentary lifestyle don't
manage your stress and have high
cholesterol levels cutting out sugar
from your diet likely isn't going to
make or break your case first of all
smoking's bad you shouldn't smoke so
while we still want to be mindful of
added sugars and prioritizing higher
fiber carbs it's really important to
take a holistic approach to diabetes
prevention by focusing on all of the
lifestyle factors rather than just
zeroing in on the amount of sugar in
your tea next is myth number five you
need to lose weight to lower your risk
of diabetes so weight loss is among the
top recommendations for folks with
pre-diabetes or diabetes with most
research pointing to the benefits of
weight loss and diabetes management and
as i mentioned earlier this is because
visceral abdominal fat increases insulin
resistance but this association is
largely specific to visceral fat and not
necessarily other types of body fat or
just having a larger body in general and
like i said you can be in a larger body
or be considered obese by bmi standards
but actually be more lean and
metabolically healthy than someone of
normal bmi and vice versa so the
recommendation to lose weight across the
board to reduce your risk of diabetes is
a bit more nuanced than absolute and
when i consulted my dietitian colleagues
and diabetes experts alita finney and
janice baker they both agreed that
focusing exclusively on weight loss is
not the best approach weight loss is not
a behavior it's a side effect and while
we can't control all of the risk factors
for diabetes we really should be zoning
in on the behaviors that we actually can
control plus if obsessing over weight
loss is causing stress and anxiety
around food and your body this can
actually increase blood sugar levels
thanks to the role of our stress hormone
cortisol dieting ultimately is a
physical and emotional stressor on the
body and chronic stress has been shown
to make our cells more insulin resistant
over time so given that weight loss is
not something that we actively have
control over janus and elita both agreed
we should be focusing on actionable
behaviors like physical activity eating
habits smoking cessation sleep and
stress management and if we lose weight
in the process then great but if we
don't then that doesn't mean that your
blood sugar levels are necessarily in
jeopardy myth number six you are more
likely to develop diabetes if you are a
person of color okay this one is a bit
of a doozy and highly controversial so i
will try my best to be succinct so one
of the most commonly cited risk factors
for diabetes is belonging to a high-risk
ethnic group however we now know that an
increased risk of diabetes is actually
far more complicated than your ethnicity
alone and actually has a lot more to do
with systemic factors affecting minority
groups we call these factors the social
determinants of health and they include
things like income working and living
conditions education physical
environment social support access to
health services as well as racism so
with that in consideration we know that
the socioeconomic disparities affecting
these ethnic groups put them at a
greater risk for not only diabetes
but for other chronic diseases as well
in fact one study found that a low
socioeconomic status was significantly
associated with type 2 diabetes among
these ethnic groups another study found
that belonging to a family of low
socioeconomic status and exposure to
environmental stressors significantly
contributed to the onset of diabetes and
other negative health outcomes among
racialized youth and this is because the
social and environmental factors impact
not only health behaviors but also
health knowledge coping skills and
access to health care moreover we also
know that racial biases and
discrimination can impact our medical
system which can increase patient stress
and hesitancy to access quality health
services so for example one large
prospective study on african american
women found that perceived racism was
strongly associated with a 16 to 31
percent increase in diabetes risk
internalized racism was also found to be
associated with diabetes diagnosis and
elevated fasting glucose furthermore
perceived racial discrimination was
associated with increased diabetes
complications as well as a two-fold
increased risk of developing a chronic
disease and a 20 to 98 percent increase
in all major risk factors so to
summarize that belonging to an ethnic
group and having an increased risk of
developing diabetes is not a you problem
and it has nothing to do with the nature
of your ethnic background instead it's a
complex systemic issue that increases
health disparities in these groups and
puts them at a disadvantage for
developing chronic disease a great
example of this is the healthy immigrant
effect where the health status of
immigrants tend to decline the longer
they remain in their host country due to
environmental factors and lack of access
to health services so to summarize can
you prevent diabetes from progressing
into diabetes yes absolutely you can the
goal is to focus on health behaviors
that not only improve insulin
sensitivity but can also help to lower
stress on the body so this includes
regular physical activity that you
actually enjoy especially aerobic and
resistance exercises and including a
balance of macros that combine carbs
into hunger crushing combos i told you
there was a lot a lot to cover but if
you have questions leave them below and
i can follow up with another video if
you'd like so on that note that is all
that i have for you guys today if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below again
any questions that you have subscribe to
the channel and i'll see you next time
on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]